good to see you Jeff Garlin hey are you
dressed in a suit oh yeah out of respect
out of respect you know amazing the bat
that you're holding him on your hand who
was Billie wife Billie Wyatt was the
caregiver see stealing home the movie
stealing home No okay that's who that is
Ellie why Mark Harmon who plays Billy
why let's just quick I'm so sorry you
suited and booted and got stuck in
traffic like by the way we live in the
most wonderful place on earth except for
one thing I dare you to find something
else it's just you just don't know it
started in Studio City gave myself an
hour come on while we're outward from
10:30 to 11:30 are you not are you going
to a deposition afterwards Rich Eisen
okay if you're going to a Bar Mitzvah
you're going to a funeral
okay okay yeah all right friend of Mines
wife I'm so sorry together Frey okay
wonderful I'm a handsome man you are a
handsome man
oh I'm remarkable young people enjoy me
what's your last item for the news it's
sad news actually Mets minor leaguer Tim
Tebow we know him we love him yeah a
good man broke a bone in his right hand
swinging the bat this weekend surgery
Tuesday likely out for the season
why should I report in this I don't know
his hashtag stick to basketball okay by
the way that would be the best thing for
baseball if he got old with the whole
trout thing about trout's not doing
drops a good guy it's baseball that
nobody gives a crap about and you need
like guys like Tim Tebow everyone's like
wow like Wendy on play baseball yeah you
know come on
but Diaw was particularly really good
edge actual of course but still the
excitement of Tebow right being in the
majors right yeah did you see Noah
syndergaard is out if they put him on
the DL we had a kid's disease hand
and now which kids gay well he said he
got it as camp yeah over the break by
the way I used to get whenever I dealt
with kids and there's a swimming pool
yeah you know counselors show but I you
get the I am so susceptible to
conjunctivitis being a traffic
I may have conjunctivitis right now
looks like Carmela Anthony is gonna sign
with the Rockets on the veterans minim
jock at dirk nowitzki one more year with
the maths for 500 well there's a there's
somebody by the way carmelo anthony is
who i saw let's go to break tell that
story there's no reason to tell that's
during the TV block then that's good to
see you Jeff it's great to see you I
don't have a few notes out of respect
respect respect that's right I love Jeff
carried my mother's grocery so I know
he's made it down the 405 we are here we
got some stark bench cuts for your since
I know you like to play that when you
ball yeah we got that game for you here
whatever you got I'm here for okay
welcome back to our show that long when
they said we're back and then there was
a pause well the TV was back the radio
wasn't back yet
oh so the the TV people knew that I was
aware the vagaries of the simulcast okay
the world you live in and I just visits
too many times to host this show when
you're gone I'm asked too many times I
will be gone August 8th are you around I
will be filming the Goldberg know I
offered you all summer I'm soaking now I
mean should I take off so you could sit
in here no you okay and that you should
not do but we'll work it out little
figure we'll get our people because you
know what I want the DirecTV people to
give me my own show
not nothing to do what would the Jeff
Garlin's Show look like do you want to
know in sincerity and sincerity to I
don't care what it looks like as long as
it's a warm feeling like this is a
really warm set thank you but it would
be me interviewing everyone from movie
stars and sports stars to garbageman
anyone is interesting talking about life
and it'd be like an hour once a
week how would you find the garbage man
that's interesting would you stand out
here like you know the guy who fixes my
TV that's not it well that the TV repair
shop okay this is not is the most
interesting guy yes Leslie I just want I
know I'm just saying someone tells me
okay
I'd find out and I'd have my producers
investigate but the point being is real
conversations with real people but and
the real people could be people like you
okay but it's just like if I had like a
Trump person on yes I would not at any
point discuss politics I would discuss
did you watch cartoons growing up and
see where that leads
like I'd want a conversation having
nothing to do with the crap that
everyone has shoved down their throat
who is the most it cuz I know you've
done you did your podcast or you still
do it or no you know no I don't do I do
the most interesting person you've
interviewed most interesting person and
you have interviewed you know I was
really taken aback and surprised by a
take Notaro
the comedian the comedian in terms of
just how crazy great and funny she was
okay
cuz I've seen you interview Soderbergh I
bet was great too or somebody everybody
was pretty much great because it's
here's the thing if you're looking to me
to do an interview yes you're looking in
the wrong place if you're looking to me
like what it'd be like if you watch me
have lunch with this person is that's
more what it is without the food with
unfortunate with other but then it
doesn't translate you know there was a
chair he has coffee with people that's
his business cars too technical don't
want cause I'm sitting in a ball game
with somebody no too much going on to
pay attention to the ball game
no done one distractions just a warm a
nice room to a people man woman man man
man whatever they want to call
themselves here whatever is there I just
go for the humanity you know and we just
people don't do that and I you think I'm
kidding by the whiteness I'm actually
gonna do this show
well whether it's here at DirecTV we
just pitched it
yeah we just pitched it I it will be on
I think they're all on a retreat I don't
know if they're watching today I don't
care says that something about it
whoever wants to do it and pay me
appropriately that's also part of it too
I get paid appropriately now we just
showed you Jeff Garlin the video that
guy they got roasted on Twitter for
social media platforms for not giving a
ball to a kid yeah apparently the young
man that's to the right of the woman who
he gave the ball to his I guess his wife
that kid got the ball as soon as they
were off off camera
she got on a phone to take a picture of
the ball before she handed it to another
kid and the kid in front who didn't get
the ball apparently got a ball from a
guy earlier right well yeah the guy's a
good guy
it's just the rush to judgment of the
internet and we have to stop it now your
show has no power that way well yes it
maybe starts with a person us and that
person is listening to your show or
watching your to us from the friendly
confines of roads so the confines were
in fact friendly they're always friendly
since they won the World Series
especially although last year when they
made it to the NL championship a lot of
people were disappointed like what world
are you living in right do you remember
anything pre to 2016 holy crap you got a
five game lead in the lost column right
yeah no we're not you know we're rocking
and I say we're because I work with the
players I develop them yeah do you want
to tell him your idea for your birth you
know it's his birthday it's Chris
Brockman's birthday yes you were kidding
me it is what are you doing I'm like
eight o'clock tonight Jeff eight o'clock
tonight I'm doing nothing you're at a
party yeah you wanna come is rich gonna
be there no because he doesn't I'm not
coming well he doesn't like my idea for
the party were your girlfriend be there
now nope dude oh okay hold on dude only
party now I'm not you know that's just
not fun wait a minute hold on is fine
strip club that's the Chris you know
look you said I've wanted to explain it
Jeff Garlin about what's happening
tonight not me cuz you didn't want me to
still tit slant it or what
you write but you have already your your
a steps behind now I'm good I'm good you
have to understand rich aizen's
attendants always important to me thank
Sarah Tiana's even more important
tonight it's fine but that's his
girlfriend for you listen arrow she look
her up on the Internet
a doll a talented lovely doll and he's
so lucky
he's so above what he deserve it's fun
even though I love him and that crazy I
think the world of him and yet he's
below Sarah Tiana Jeff you like fantasy
sports right you like you like drafting
like the way the draft in fantasy
baseball is more fun than than the
season okay without it and you also like
eating and like being with your friends
yes we have combined those two things
into one we please please elaborate we
do a hamburger draft we go to a place
called 26 beach in Venice California
they have about 30 gourmet hamburgers on
their menu yes we have everyone in
attendance picks one burger yeah
everyone does a different burger we
didn't have those burgers cut in half
and then when they get delivered we do a
fantasy draft of all the different
burgers yeah and then we have a great
party we eat we drink we'd be merry I'm
going without gluten now so I'd have to
just eat them and then get not just one
ate too much meat I'm not coming also
it's in Venice I'm across town what
about the by the way happy perfect I
don't wanna like make you think I don't
wish you a happy birthday and or Sarah
Tiana was there I'd be there and that
tells you a lot about you
would you like to come now rich what's
that no no uh-uh rich doesn't like this
idea rich you know I know you're having
dinner this week this week here's why
here's here's it's not because of who
you are it's because of who you are
inside well I want to have dinner with
you you understand right about a second
my wife feels the same way that she says
she feels about me and that you feel
about me yeah you're the Sarah Tiana in
this situation she loves you
yeah okay she loves Jeff Garlin yeah so
it's a it's a no brainer we're going to
dinner yes but the reason why I'm going
to
with you and not to what Chris Brockman
has invited me to for his birthday he
was running when you and I and Susy have
dinner Friday night
yeah we will get a menu yes we will then
select what we want to eat yes because
let's be honest we're all busy people
right all have children we got going on
that when we leave the house for an hour
and a half two hours to make time for
ourselves I'm not leaving it up to
chance that I don't want to eat
something that I don't want to eat Susie
told me we were drafting our food truly
happy birthday but no thank you Jim
okay that's really the summarization
happy happy birthday now is it a gluten
thing is that why you're saying no I
don't eat wheat I don't eat dairy
I do have goat yogurt though I don't do
cow's milk
I don't do wheat since when recently
enough but sugar now I'm going on ten
months no sugar damn yeah Wow and like
this morning I had some Trader Joe's
rice cereal you know and I ate it and I
felt like crap and then I looked and
there was sugar so I mean in it it was
not a sugar researcher and I just
thought I don't even eat it subtly and
or it affects me boom and the weights
flying off and the muscles are growing
boom and the excitement is building in
America as I personally slowed down the
internet with my newfound power how much
have you lost I don't know I don't mind
myself you know my word I do not weigh
myself I know I'm somewhere in the two
40s so then I was at my highest during
maybe daddy daycare days or earlier and
curb I was as high as 3 20 no way yeah
I'm two forties
what are you wearing the same belt oh my
stuff gets smaller I'm just saying don't
weigh myself no what I'm saying is like
can you not say that you're now getting
two more notches or the same belt it
would loop around twice okay there you
go
it was great baby you did great you do
think I feel great all right I want to
take a break we'll come back and take a
break you're correct I don't I do have
to take a break yeah in terms of
promotion well I'm trying to it's a team
they
there is no I in well there is an eye on
Fox Sports Radio right at the end you
know we're all the team we're all team
they need a 60-second break I'm gonna
give it to him okay so I'm not type of
guy come back and then we've got some
good start bench cuts for you you got a
bench one you got a cut all right and we
haven't even discussed the Bears we have
not news I got big bears news for me
back in 60 seconds that's what we call a
tease all right welcome back to the
Rajesh show are you back on Twitter no
you're not pretending to be mates at at
the Jeff Garlin the judges got you
there's not me looks like doesn't say
verified though does it there's no blue
check nope if I'm on Twitter it's how
long till I say something that annoys
someone and it's that you've been off
Twitter for a couple of years right yes
I went off I had about 150,000 followers
I didn't even say a mass goodbye I just
was gone because I knew as I said I
think Twitter is bad for someone who's
in the public eye and there's someone
proving that day by day who was the
young lady who does the countdown you're
threatening Britney she's lovely big
bowl of lovely pink boa lovely Britt
good to see you Britney is that when you
countdown like no other person such a
good countdown er from well I mean what
do you like your count from ten five no
I
you like a five count attend no no no no
I like any count that Britney does
that's what Jeff Garlin flirting that's
me sincere well your Britney was Brent
I'd say the same same started countdown
being the same way okay
all right she is lovely but that's so is
the the I guess hypothetical Brent Brent
is a doll Brent Musburger by the way I
know with the hold on Oh
no no I must burger doing the Raiders
you and I first heard brent musburger no
locally in Chicago that's right right
locally in Chicago as a kid I remember
it vividly then suddenly was on CBS
they said Chicago guy and then they had
the slow-motion nobody does it better
with film of Walter Payton and to this
day nobody does it better so what's your
bears news my bears news is this for the
2020 season a 2019 season next year I
will be a season ticket holder sitting
on the 50-yard line
the gentleman who has the seats is doing
this year and I'm paying him my seat
licensing fee and I'm taking over
tickets that were in another family for
generations and I'm in and I'm gonna be
going to the bear game sitting with the
people so what caused you to do this
because I love of the Bears I know you
hold on you know you love of the Bears
yeah I've seen it I understand it yes
but you were kind of turned off by the
Bears very much so but currently turned
on what what do you say when you send me
sort of wife Suzy a stick but it's not
sexual
the coach what is what has caused you to
the coach
it's too risky it's the other coaches
it's the attitude around palace hall I
am Pro Chicago Bear
I've always been it hurts so bad when
they're bad
I don't expect great things this year I
expect improvement and I know there will
be yes but starting next year when I'm
sitting there Oh we'll see some great
things
oh we will see some great thing so
you're locked in for 2019 I am locked in
for 20 long games all eight home know
when it gets too cold and going out
selling watch it on the DirecTV put a
lot of faces like a big bears-packers
game you're going I don't care if it's
below zero okay no I'm not I'm staying
home but the point being it's like the
Cubs in the World Series against the
Indians yeah I didn't go to Cleveland
but you would you do it all three to
Wrigley
I'm not going to Cleveland even for a
World Series right I'm not going just
like that I'm not going below zero well
I think that kind of leads us in a way
to some start bench car prayer okay
first one for Jeff Garlin you have the
okay first one you have to start one you
have to bench and cut one okay
best Chicago food deep-dish pizza
Chicago style hot dog Italian beef start
bench cut start Pizza bench hotdog cut
Italian beef gone
yeah what's it's got to be cut I know
that so but I'm not a big Italian beef
guy surprisingly Chicago I love my
little Malnati's and I love the hot dog
that's your Chicago my Chicago is Lou
Malnati's with the butter crust and then
and I will make a gluten exceptions and
when I get a great Vienna hotdog that's
done right I'll also make my gluten
except otherwise in gluten if session
was that an Allman Brothers song that
was a good clean no but I also want to
add that the only exception I don't make
is sugar like I'll have gluten every
once in a while something else dairy in
it but I do not very well veer away from
added sugar so I guess then this one
will be interesting best condiment on a
hot dog ketchup mustard relish start
bench cut Jeff Koch a hot dog mustard
bench relish cut come on ketchup does
not thank you Jeff if you're from
America little boy at heart aren't you I
have little boys put ketchup on their
hot dog I am yeah you've never become a
man I know I was bar mitzvah'd a long
time ago okay but clearly not when it
comes to that sort of stuff good next
one
best movie based in Chicago yeah Ferris
Bueller's Day Off The Untouchables Blues
Brothers start bad why are you doing
this dark bench cut
start the Blues Brothers I bench ferris
bueller and I cut the untouchable yeah
we were gonna include the fugitive in
this is that a Chicago that would have
been not even up it is in Chicago and
and all good and fine by the way you
didn't include one of my favorites I
want someone to eat cheese with oh of
course you and the lovely Sarah
Silverman starring yes film yes
based in Chicago yes so you want the
Blues Brothers right Blues Brothers but
not I'm on a mission from God I know I
am I'm on a mission from a higher power
I don't know what it is next rx1 have
you think Jeff Garlin athlete you most
want back in professional sports
okay Johnny Manziel Tim Tebow Ronda
Rousey start bench cut all right I start
Tim Tebow I bench rounder Rousey run
however say your name Ronda Rousey
rounder Rousey who really I don't follow
her I know who she is I don't really
care much and you know Johnny Manziel I
wish him well but leave me alone but you
cutting him yeah why do you start Tebow
you because he'd be great for baseball I
don't want him starting a football I
want him starting in the Mets outfield
because I want baseball it'd be great
for baseball baseball doesn't have
enough of people like Tim Tebow they
don't have anybody like I know and it's
not it's not Mike trout's fault he's
just a great baseball player but and
that's great for people who already
baseball fans if you're not a baseball
fan you don't give a crap about Mike you
know Dan Patrick doesn't hot take at all
but he said that Tebow is the most
famous player in baseball right now
without a doubt nobody can touch him
nobody who's more famous than Mookie
Betts by the way I love my love the Red
Sox but holy crap is pretty famous no
it's not not table not in New York
people really do Tebow is by far the
most popular player in base but how many
people know that he plays baseball
everyone who casually watches any sports
center that's but I think I can
jewelle sports fan knows that he's
playing baseball the casual sports fan
says who's Erin judge and also I mean
wouldn't you know even if he's so sure
and you're not competent because I am
sure you are not sure sir and I am John
your birthday all day should be sure and
you're not sure
last one for you Jeff currently the curb
character most likely to talk during
Tigers backswing Larry
Leon or Susie okay then Susie then Larry
because what cuz Larry no Larry respects
golf yes but Larry what would say it for
the wrong reason like that would be the
humor in it right he doesn't mean to but
he does Susie is I don't give a crap and
Liang Liang's just doing it it's not
even a matter of not caring he at all
times is gonna say and do something so
the but did the show get in the show got
nominated right yes we're nominated for
an Emmy yes and Larry was for Best Actor
and yeah good luck to us yeah good luck
exactly I want to take a break come back
talk a little bit about that and and
other things and we got another
countdown it's very exciting
yes when we come back Britney will count
down Jeff Garlin back into the final
segment of the show yeah
we need do we need if we need a
refresher you'll need a good birthday no
gluten the gluten-free sugar-free
dairy-free dairy-free Jeff Garden yep
Garlan here on the Rich Eisen show would
you call it was that the Rif music radio
so radio has a little bit like we're
like a little bit delayed okay
televisions always back the final poll
results brought to you by Calloway
Odyssey XO odds are you've played in
Odyssey putter before but I have one you
don't like Callaway's the new XO putter
from Odyssey combines multi material
construction with a white-hot micro
hinge insert for incredible feel role
and forgiveness preorder it today at
Odyssey golf common other apologized to
golf I'm learning how to golf I take
golf lessons I have them tomorrow
morning okay great and because I faked
play golf on curb but now I'm actually
learning and I got some Callaway golf
club okay which they didn't give me for
free but as a huge discount and they
gave you lots of hats and balls and all
but I love my Callaway Club I love them
I gave LD I gave Larry when he was here
a box of Rich Eisen show logo golf balls
you have more I'm more than happy to
hand them to please well but I have to
give you full disclosure you're not good
they're great go soft okay he then cut a
a text of complaint then they were
distracting oh yeah logo no I had my
name on the ball come out of his rhythm
what if I told you it'll do the opposite
for me it will call me okay it will
relax me it will let me know the world
is a good place so I should be playing
golf rich I can't wait for those have
you ever seen Larry putt can we show the
video of Larry putting on the Callaway
corner to to Jeff Garlin please he gets
down all the way down says that's how he
putts he puts his hand away he's an
idiot
I love that man so deeply he is one of
my best friends in the world
yeah but that is ridiculous Eze he does
that for real and do you know he does
that on the set he'd like practices on
the set no I don't know though it's
wrong but he just
like standing around he starts doing the
swing I'm like enough in between takes
in between takes
during takes heat okay when are you back
doing this we started October 19th
fantastic yes
oh do you know what do you have anything
yet do you know anything yet I know
everything you do what if I told you as
far as I'm concerned this season might
be my favorite storyline of all time oh
it's not big like last year's a fatwa
like a big thing right or a sweet subtle
thing it's beautiful like the Seinfeld
reunion and stuff like that I mean I
better than that it's more about the
when you're in this situation and you
see something in your imagination goes
oh man if I only I could do that and
Larry David can do that I don't want to
say anymore it's a big bowl of right I
love it
Wow I'm so excited about it so you've
seen you've seen the plot lines cuz I've
read all the scripts I've read them all
it's great I'm so happy I can't wait and
I think if you're a real curb fan like a
hardcore curb and this might be one of
your this will be one of your favorite
seasons of all time is it is it the last
one do you think well might be for me
things to do
I've been on the show a long time let me
ask you a question yes I can't say it
wait what's the final poll results we
got to pay it off for our forensic Allen
loves the show it's an honor during the
show but I'm not under contract after
this season
I'll see what I got you okay so we'll
see now let's double look let the merger
happen then everyone will sit here
merger okay yeah HBO we'll get you right
we'll get it right okay you watch tiger
over the weekend Jeff watching my caddie
form there you go how many more majors
is Tiger gonna win the rest of his
career
1:02 Plus Oh what do you think
I think it's Tiger Woods yes could be a
two plus what's the club plus 30% one
leads the way 42% 28% zero well I think
the zero is probably the greatest
I think so but but tights Tiger one all
right you could see them getting a
groove it like 40 where you go where did
this come from because it's Tiger Woods
I know
21 years old so that was that would be
tough
all right well 44 I just saying in
general if you come out of nowhere and
it's Tiger Woods he's Tiger Woods I mean
that he's mentioned in the same breath
with two other golfers three yeah
four right there's three good golfers
Hogan yeah Nicholas and Arnie Arnie
Palmer so those are that's the five okay
I didn't want to be I didn't have the
older to migrate away Hogan and Bobby
Jones but come on man and then after we
give you a box of the chrome soft a
bunch and Jeff Garlin no you will never
be mentioned Jeff Garlin thanks for
coming on today well that's it well they
were playing the theme music so we are
done oh I do a nice in overtime with it
Mary Kay Mary Kate Cabot rich Lerner
tomorrow show David Spade will be here
oh and Don Mattingly will be on the show
all right
in person no calling in it's the 35th
anniversary of the pine tar game that he
played in
oh great grandma's balls will see the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience